I do find him different than he was back
then um I didn't see hints of this kind
of harmful Behavior back then yeah John
Legend might be missing the old Kanye
West I missed the old Kanye straight
from the go Kanye the singer explaining
why his decades-long friendship with the
rapper has changed he's the one that
signed me he's the one that helped
discover me and helped me get a record
deal and I wouldn't be where I am now
without him so I'm very grateful to him
but now John singing a different
one with Kara Swisher podcast saying
that Kanye who once helped his career is
different from the man he is now you
know I think life happens to people and
I think the death of his mother probably
had something to do with this I think
and you know I don't want to play
armchairs psychologist but he's
definitely changed and a lot of us who
have known him over the years are really
concerned about you're referring to
mental illness that he's talked about it
himself absolutely the two artists have
a long history together both
collaborating on each other's early
music first on Kanye's 2004 album The
College Dropout
[Music]
and John he was one of yay's first
artists on his new label at the time
good music I'm gonna make sure that I
sit down I mean all the way from the
videos to the marketing to the timing
like I really want to be involved with
the artist careers and give them the
best advice that I can give them
Ordinary People
we don't know which way to go see
director Ordinary People and it helped
me pick my photographer for the you know
their album photo session and he just
helped with a lot of things because he's
been through it all he's I'm basically
kind of a year behind what he did last
year so he gave me a lot of great advice
but fast forward to now and yay's been
stirring up controversy including making
several anti-black and anti-semitic
comments Jewish media was pushing the
narrative off the White live
White lives matter t-shirt that I didn't
love black people and I guess it came
off and I came back and I was like no
[ __ ] the Jewish media and John shares
that while they're no longer in contact
he knows people are worried about him I
know people in his life that are but we
have lost touch we've not been friends
for a while now and uh so I'm not
personally doing anything but I do know
people who are and you know a lot of
people are concerned about him but for
someone who supposedly uh free thinking
and independently thinking Landing back
at these uh very tried and true forms of
hate and bigotry
um it's harmful and it doesn't help
anyone and if there's any room for
forgiveness for Kanye John explains his
thoughts on that I believe in
forgiveness in general that doesn't mean
people shouldn't face consequences for
what they do wrong but I also do believe
in forgiveness
[Music]